AFRAID IT MIGHT WARM UP WITH
BUT ANY RATE I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND CALL- TODAY'S WEDNESDAY
JANUARY TWENTY SECOND MEETING
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE TO
ORDER. AND ASK OUR SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS BATES
MINING MINING HERE ROTH ROTH
HERE WILL PRESENT WILL HEAR
ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE BATES
HERE. THANK YOU- BEFORE WE
START WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE SAID- HERE AND
REQUIRED TO APPEAR I AM GOING
TO TRY TO ESTABLISH- CONSENT
CALENDAR AND I KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO SEPARATE A FEW THINGS
OUT SO. I WOULD RECOMMEND- ITEM
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM THREE
REFERRAL OF BILLS ITEM FOR THE
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE ITEM FIVE
SELECT COMMITTEE REQUESTS.
ITEMS X. SELECT COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS. I'M GOING TO SKIP
SEVEN AND GO TO EIGHT THROUGH
THIRTEEN WHICH ARE FLOOR
ECONOMIC TRENDS AND REQUEST
THAT CONSENT CALENDAR I HAVE
PULLED OUT ITEM SEVEN FOUR
SEPARATE VOTE. SO THE MOVIE
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
ARE WE GOOD ON THAT OKAY. MAN
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES AYE BATES AYE
MONNING MONNING I RAFI. RAFI I
WILL WILK AYE ATKINS HI CAN
SIGN I WILL ASK FOR A MOTION ON
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN RETARDED
MILITANT. THANK YOU SENATOR-
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS BATES
NUMBER THE MORNING. MORNING I
ROTH ROTH AYE WILK WILK AYE
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE THAT
PASSES AND THEREFORE WE ARE
BACK TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES LET ME
INVITE THE FIRST TWO APPOINTEES
MR NAVAJO AND- MISS PATILLO
BROWNSON COME FORWARD AND
WELCOME. AND I WILL- ASK IN
YOUR INTRODUCTION YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS IF THERE'S ANYONE YOU
WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND THANKS
FOR BEING HERE IN PARTICULAR-
AND THEN- MAKE YOUR COMMENTS
AND THEN AFTER BOTH OF YOU HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT WE
WILL GO TO COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. HOW ABOUT WE START
WITH YOU. MY NAME IS KIM TAYLOR
BROWN SEN AND I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE MY HUSBAND'S A MARK
RONSON WHO'S HERE WITH ME
TODAY. X. SO SENATOR PRO TEM
ATKINS AND SENATORS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU AND TO BE CONSIDERED
FOR CONFIRMATION TO THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. I THINK
IT'S PARTICULARLY FITTING- THAT
TODAY'S CONFIRMATION HEARING
COMES ON THE HEELS OF MARTIN
LUTHER KING DAY AND- WHICH WAS
JUST THIS WEEKEND. I BELIEVE
THAT EDUCATION IS A CORNERSTONE
FOR CREATING PATHWAYS FOR
CALIFORNIANS- TO EXPERIENCE
SOCIAL ECONOMIC ABILITY.
FAIRNESS EQUITY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ROBUST EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES. IN A WAY THAT I TAKE
TO BE SYNONYMOUS WITH DOCTOR
KING'S VISION. MY OWN LIFE PATH
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE
BUT FOR WHAT I THINK OF IT THE
BEAUTY OF CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATIONAL PROMISE. ITS
ABILITY TO LIFT UP HARD WORKING
KIDS OF ALL COLORS AND STRIPES-
WHETHER THEY WERE BORN TO
TITANS OF INDUSTRY OR OF THE
MOST HUMBLE OF FAMILIES. I'VE
SEEN AND EXPERIENCED
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
WORKING AND WORKING WELL AND
I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT. EVERY KID IN
CALIFORNIA HAS THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THIS BE TWENTY TWENTY. THE
DAWNING OF A NEW DECADE. I
THINK IT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY
AND THE PRIVILEGE OF THIS
PARTICULAR MOMENT. CLEAR EYED
IN ARCTIC HOW AND WHAT EXPECT
OF CALIFORNIANS EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM TO BE A SYSTEM OF
OPPORTUNITY EXCELLENCE IN
BUILDING STRONG CHILDREN TO
CONTRIBUTE. TO CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUED SUCCESS
STORY IN THIS DECADE AND FOR
MANY TO COME. TO ME BEING CLEAR
EYED ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
EDUCATION REQUIRES A FEW
FUNDAMENTALS FIRST STARTING
EARLY AND BUILDING STRONG
CHILDREN FROM THE BEGINNING
THIS MEANS STRENGTHENING EARLY
LEARNING. AND CONNECTING EARLY
LEARNING TO K. TO TWELVE SECOND
I THINK IT MEANS SUPPORT
SUPPORTING ROBUST TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY UNDER THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
SO THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES CAN
BE PARTNERS. IN ACCOUNTABILITY
AND LOCAL DECISION MAKING AND
CLOSING PERSISTENT ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS. THESE ARE IMPORTANT CON
CORNERSTONES FOR THE CONTINUED
IMPROVEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AND I WOULD
BE HONORED. TO SERVE THE BOARD
IN THIS CAPACITY I'M GRATEFUL
TO HAVE BEEN APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR AN HONOR TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR CONFIRMATION BY
THE- TEAM. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. IT
DOMINO NOT I'M NOT GONNA READ I
RESENT THE FACT THAT I'M LOSING
MY EYESIGHT. YEAH AS LONG SO
I'M IF YOU DON'T MIND I'M- WHEN
I TRY GO BY MEMORY AND JUST
TELL YOU WHAT I'M FEELING FROM-
MY HEART AND AS A FORMER
SUPERINTENDENT BREVITY IS
NORMALLY NOT MY FRIEND I'M
GONNA TRY TO WORK ON THAT
TODAY- BUT I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY FAMILY. WHO IT'S
NOT EASY TO GET THREE TEENAGERS
UP AT FIVE THIRTY IN THE
MORNING TO GET TO SACRAMENTO.
BUT THEY DID AND I HAVE MY
THREE SONS OF MY BEAUTIFUL WIFE
HERE- BRITAIN KENNEDY CONTRACT
AND TIGHTLY THANK YOU- I'VE
BEEN EDUCATION FOR- JUST OVER
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS NINETEEN OF
THAT WAS SPENT IN A LITTLE
DISTRICT OUTSIDE FRESNO CALLED
SINGER UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT-
FOR THOSE HE THAT WERE. FIELD
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
UNIFIED WAS ANOINTED AS THE-
LOWEST PERFORMING SCHOOL
DISTRICT OF BOTTOM 2% SCHOOLS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
THERE WAS THE TOWN THAT WHEN
YOU DROVE IN IT SAID WELCOME TO
SANGER NATION'S CHRISTMAS TREE
CITY. AND RIGHT ABOVE THAT SAID
WELCOME TO SANGER HOME OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND HAPPY TEACHERS.
SOUL I- CUT MY TEETH IN A
DISTRICT. THAT BLESSING EXAMPLE.
THAT CHANGE CAN HAPPEN- THAT
YOU CAN MOVE THE NEEDLE- YOU
CAN MOVE THE NEEDLE FOR
CHILDREN IN NEED I AM A PRODUCT
OF PUBLIC EDUCATION MYSELF MY
MOTHER- WHO SINGLE FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME AND- I SURVIVED BASED
ON HER FORTITUDE AND
COURAGEOUS- TRINA- HABITS. TO
KEEP A YOUNG MAN WHO IS A
DIFFICULT TO CONTROL ON THE
RIGHT PATH. AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT I MINISTER FATHER WHO
OPENED MY EYES TO EDUCATION.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT I WAS
EXPOSED TO STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND I FELL IN LOVE
SERVING STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND THAT'S WHAT
BRINGS ME HERE I HOPE TO BRING
TO THE BOARD- PERSPECTIVE. FROM
THE LOCAL EDUCATOR PROTECT
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS- TO BE A
VOICE FOR THOSE THAT DON'T
OFTEN HAVE IT AND TO BE A VOICE
OF IT IS POSSIBLE THEIR
IMPROVEMENT CAN HAPPEN- IN LACK
OF FUNDING. AN IMPROVEMENT CAN
HAPPEN EVEN IN THE FACE
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES. I LIVED
IT FOR X. AMOUNT OF TIME. I'M
HONORED TO BE NOMINATED BY
GOVERNOR SOME AND I WELCOME.
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
BEEN CONSIDERATION NOMINATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A LET ME
ASK SENATOR ROTH IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO START. APPROACH HIM
FIRST CONGRATULATIONS FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE YOUR OR
CONTINUED CONTINUING TO SERVE.
AS THE CASE MAY BE- RESUMES ARE
VERY VERY IMPRESSIVE I LOOK
FORWARD TO. MOVING HERE
CONFIRMATION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME JUST ONE QUICK QUESTION A
MY PERCEPTION IS THAT THE-
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE IMPORTANT
MEDITATION OF OUR- EL CAP AND
I'LL SEE IF OF PROCESS. IS
UNEVEN AT BEST ACROSS THE STATE.
WHAT ROLE DO YOU THINK WHAT
IMPORTANT ROLE DO YOU THINK
THAT THE BOARD HAS IN ENSURING
BOTH THE- LET THE LC HEALTHCARE
PROCESSES BOTH INCLUSIVE. AND
EFFECTIVE. IF IT'S A FAIR
QUESTION YES. THE BOTH OF US WE
JUST PEPPER ONE ACCORD OKAY FOR
BOTH SO- I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
QUITE HONESTLY THE TENSION
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW FOR
THE FIRST TIME- WE HAVE SEEN
POSITIVE RESULTS AS A RESULT OF
THE WORK THAT LOCALS ARE DOING
AND GRAPPLING WITH WITH LOCAL
CONTROL WE HAVE. LESS SCHOOLS
IN NEED OF DIFFERENCE
ASSISTANCE AND WE SAW AN UPTICK
IN MANY OF OUR- INDICATORS
OUTSIDE OF CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
IN FACT ONE OF THE SUB GROUPS
THAT HAD THE STEEPNESS OF
GREENS WAS STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES THE BALANCING ACT
IS CREATING A MECHANISM WHERE
WE CAN HEAR THE STAKEHOLDERS AT
THE STATE BOARD. AND WE LISTEN
TO THOSE STAKEHOLDERS AND WE
DON'T- DEVELOP IN MY OPINION.
EL CAP THAT IS EVER ONE AND
DONE IT'S A FOR GOING TO MODEL
IMPROVEMENT ACROSS THE STATE
AND THE IDEA FOR THE STATE
BOARD IS THAT WE- TESTED. WE
SEE IF IT CAPTURES THE ESSENCE
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROVE
AND WE LET THE DATA DRIVES THE
OUTCOMES WE LET THE DATA DRIVES
THE INTENSITY OF RESOURCE
ALLOCATION AND THE- SUPPORTS
THAT ARE NEEDED SO FOR ME I
THINK AT AS A STATE BOARD I
THINK IT'S AN INCUMBENT THAT WE
HEAR THE STAKEHOLDERS- WE HEAR
THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE
HAVING WITH REGARDS TO.
UNDERSTANDING THE ELCA MAKING
SENSE F THE OKAY UP IN TERMS
OF WHERE MONEY IS GOING AND HOW
IT'S BEING CATERED AT THE SAME
TIME WE BALANCED OUT BY.
ANALYZING THE DATA HIGHLIGHTING
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE THAT ARE
WORKING ACROSS OUR STATE- AND-
MAKE THEM VISIBLE AND HAD.
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER SO THAT
WE CAN LEARN SO AS A STATE
BOARD MEMBER I WOULD CERTAINLY
BE INTERESTED IN STATE WATER.
BACK CERTAIN. IN FIND THAT
POLAND. CHOIRS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO. AND YOU'VE SEEN THE
OBVIOUSLY SOME FROM SOME
QUARTERS ANYWAY KERR OF OUR- IN
THAT- NUMBER ONE THE MONEY THAT
IS THE EXTRA MONEY THAT IS
DESIGNED TO. SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE IN THE FORM OF
CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDS IN
THE LAKE ARE NECESSARILY
REACHING THOSE POPULATIONS
LEAST REPORTEDLY IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO. THAT THE EL CAP PROCESS-
AT LEAST IN SOME QUARTERS IS
ARGUABLY A CHECK THE BOX
PROCESS AND NOT. NEARLY WHAT WE
ANTICIPATED WHEN WE HAD THE
DEBATE OVER LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING AND THE PROCESS FOR
THAT SEVERAL YEARS AGO MA'AM.
AND YES I AM I THINK ONE OF THE
INTERESTING DESCRIPTIONS I'VE
HEARD OF LATE S LEARNING
POLICY INSTITUTE. IN CAPS
LEADING THE L. CFF SHIFT- AS
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST EXPERIMENT
IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IN ITS
HISTORY- OF MOVING. WHAT IS
ROUGHLY 40% OF THE STATE BUDGET
TO LOCAL DECISION MAKING- AT
THE ELLIE A LEVEL. I DO THINK
THERE HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE-
ATTEMPTS OF ESSENTIALLY
ITERATING SO LCF WAS PASSED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN- WE JUST
ADOPTED THE FOURTH ITERATION OF
THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY- TEMPLATE- IN
CHANGE TWO WEEKS AGO- AT THE
STATE BOARD MEETING AND AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR- AND EACH
ITERATION I THINK IS GETTING.
GETTING CLOSER- TO SOMETHING
THAT I THINK REACHES
ASPIRATIONS THAT ANY OF US HAD
FOR THIS PROCESS- WHAT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I THINK ALSO
THAT WE ADOPTED IN THE JANUARY
BOARD PROCESS WAS A REQUIREMENT
AROUND HAVING. ELEAZAR DESCRIBE
WHAT- THEY HEARD FROM
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND THEN ALSO WHAT
COMPONENTS WERE ADOPTED
INCORPORATED- IT'S KIND OF AN
INTERESTING- REQUIREMENT BUT IT
IT'S ONE THAT IS REALLY I THINK
GEARED TOWARDS MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE SEE. THE VALUE OF
PARTICIPATION- THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR INPUT WAS
HEARD INCORPORATED AND MOVE THE
NEEDLE AND THAT'S I THINK A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION OF WHAT
OF A CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. SMALL THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS SHOULD
ENCOMPASS- I ALSO THINK THERE
IS. PRIOR TO OUR TIME AN
APPOINTMENT ON THE BOARD- THE-
NEW BUDGET SUMMARY FOR PARENTS-
IS AIMED AT- SIR STREAMLINING
WHAT IS- SERVE UNPACKED FOR
PARENTS IN PARTICULAR SO THAT
WE- WE SAW A BALLOONING OF-
SORT OF THE LENGTH OF EL CAP TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL- IN MY- HOME
SCHOOL DISTRICT OF LAUSD- AT A
CERTAIN POINT IT WAS ALMOST
THREE HUNDRED PAGES- AND IT'S-
IT'S- REASONABLE TO EXPECT.
THAT PARENTS SHOULD DECIDE FOR
ALL OF OUR SECONDS AND- YOU
KNOW GOBBLEDYGOOK OF ACRONYMS
ENOUGH THAT SUIT. TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING AND
SO THE BUDGET SUMMARY FOR
PARENTS I THINK IS AN ATTEMPT
TO CORRECT FOR THAT AND TO.
SPEAK PLAINLY ABOUT HOW THIS IS
SHAPING. OPERATE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN- IS WHAT WE DROPPED IT
IN JANUARY PERFECT I'D I DON'T
THINK SO BUT ARE WE DONE NO. I
THINK- IT IS VERY VERY MUCH MY
ASPIRATION AND I THINK THAT'S
VERSION OF MANY MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD TO CONTINUE. TO ACTUALLY
LISTEN TO THE STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK- AND ALSO ITERATE IN
THE FUTURE TO MAKE SURE. THAT
THIS IS A ROBUST A PROCESSES
POSSIBLE AND THAT LOCAL
DECISION MAKERS HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF KNOWING FROM PARENTS
FROM COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHAT'S
WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT. WELL I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR FOCUS YOU CONTINUED FOCUS
ON THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO. CERTAINLY ALL OF US
IN THIS BUILDING AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
PERPETRATOR THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM. THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM- GAME CONGRATULATIONS ON
THAT POINT A REAPPOINTMENT
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
BUT I APPRECIATE THE FACT YOU
MENTION SO CALLED SOCIAL
EQUITY. BECAUSE THIS IS BY THE
BASS BEST PATHWAY. IN EVERY
SHARED UP. THERE'S A LOT OF
THERE'S A LOT OF DEFICIENCIES
IN THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM I
REALLY ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION. AND I THINK WE
AGREED A LOT OF STUFF IN
PARTICULAR APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION. I FEEL LIKE WE ALL
DO NOT FOR THE COMMUNITY- SO
WITH THAT AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS
EXPECT TO. SUPPORT YOUR
NOMINATION TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES THANK
YOU I THINK THAT THE US SENATE
TO ROCKLAND SENATOR WILL JUST
COVERED ALL OF MY QUESTIONS.
MOST IMPRESSED HIM PRESSURES
AND PRESS THEM. FROM BOTH OF
YOU IS A COMMITMENT TO HAVE
THEIR SAY REAL- INTERACTIVE
THOUGHT PROCESS WITH YOUR
STAKEHOLDERS. AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE BOTH BEEN VERY HIGH ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF PARENT
PARTICIPATION IN THANK YOU FOR
THAT DISCUSSION AND FOR
ALLOWING ME TO VENT ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT ARE. IN THERE BOTH
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT I MADE
A POINT THAT I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF VOUCHERS I THINK
THAT WE CANNOT TAKE. MONEY FROM
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT
WE CAN MAKE PUBLIC SCHOOL SAM
OF MORE MORE- I THINK BLACK
CIVIL IN TERMS OF THE KIDS. ARE
THAT NEED OF THOSE LITTLE
DIFFERENT PATHWAYS AND YOU KNOW
AND I BELIEVE THAT CHARTERS
PROVIDE THAT SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND MOST IMPORTANTLY. YOUR
BACKGROUNDS ARE SO IMPRESSIVE
MUSCLES THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITMENT THAT YOU. AID TO
THIS MOST IMPORTANT PRIORITY IN
OUR STATE FOR PRESS OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS SO YEAH MY ****
PARTY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO. ON
THAT COMPETITION A HAND I WILL.
BE OF AT ANY TIME AND WE NEED
CONVERSE. SO THANK YOU BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR
MINING THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND THAT MY CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU BOTH SEN THANKS FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE THE STATE
BRINGING YEAR RESPECTIVE
EXPERIENCE- AND TALENTS TO THE
SERVICE OF OUR STATE I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOUR FAMILIES FOR
THEIR SUPPORT. I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY ARE SURE THEY KNOW THEY'RE
GETTING INTO. BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THEIR THEIR ROLE AS
PARTNERS IN THIS- I ENJOYED MY
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH EACH
OF YOU. ALTHOUGH BRIEFLY. IN
OUR COLD OFFICES THIS MORNING-
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO THE
SAME. SYSTEM BUT ON A SERIOUS
NOTE FROM. WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT SOME. ETHNIC STUDIES
AND SOME RECENT CHALLENGES OF
EITHER POOR MCCUE COMMUNICATION
LACK OF- INCLUSION JUST KIND OF
YOUR THOUGHT SON NOT ONLY HOW
WE MOVE FORWARD AS A STATE BUT-
IN YOUR OWN VIEWS BY ETHNIC
STUDIES IS IMPORTANT IN A STATE
AS DIVERSE AS CALIFORNIA THE
KIND OF RELATED TO THAT
ALTHOUGH. A SEPARATE AREA BUT
HOW WE CONTINUE TO INCREASE OUR
FOCUS ON EARLY EDUCATION- AND
RECOGNIZING PARTICULAR NEEDS
THAT MIGHT MANIFEST AMONG
PARTICULARLY YOUNG CHILDREN SO
THAT THEY CAN GET THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER SO. AND YOU WANNA LEAD ON
IN WILL FOLLOW WITH MISTER
NOVEL THANKS- SIR- FIRST ON
ETHNIC STUDIES. THE FIRST PIECE
I THINK- I THINK THAT THE
ADOPTION OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM IS GOING TO BE QUITE
IMPORTANT- TO ARE INCREASINGLY
DIVERSE- SCHOOL CHILDREN ACROSS
THE STATE AND HAVING CHILDREN
BE ABLE TO SEE THEMSELVES IN
THE HISTORY. AND THE SORT OF
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT HAVE BUILT-
THE POWER HOUSE THAT IS OUR
HOME STATE- IS REALLY
SOMETHING- THAT THAT CAN BE-
SORT OF CABIN REALLY- THERE ARE
CHAPTERS THAT I THINK WILL BE
UNCONTROVERSIAL ABOUT- THE
FARMWORKERS ABOUT THE
SUFFRAGETTE MOVEMENT ABOUT- THE
AT CHINESE- RAILROAD- AT
BUILDING. AND CONTRIBUTIONS
ACROSS- MANY SORT OF SEGMENTS
OF A OUR CALIFORNIA HISTORY BUT
ALSO OUR NATIONAL HISTORY. AND
I THINK THAT IS ABSOLUTELY A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I
THINK THE PROCESS FOR THE
ETHNIC STUDIES- ADOPTION HAS
BEEN A LITTLE FADED- TO SAY THE
LEAST- AND I THINK THERE ARE
ALSO MECHANISMS THAT WERE
ALREADY UNDERTAKING- TO CREATE
A BETTER PROCESS- ON. A SERVE
ON THE SCREENING COMMITTEE FOR
THE STATE BOARD- FOR
APPOINTMENTS TO THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
VETTING FOR- IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS A SPIRIT OF
INCLUSION- A SPIRIT OF OPENNESS
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT- WE
ASKED ALL THE CANDIDATES WAS.
ON TO DESCRIBE A SITUATION
WHERE THEY HAVE HAPPENED TO
WORK WELL UNDER PUT IDEA JEEZ
AND HOW THEY ACTUALLY DONE SO
CONSTRUCTIVELY WE WERE JOKING
AT LUNCH WITH THE THAT. I'M. AT
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A GOOD
COMPROMISE WITH. EVERYONE A
LITTLE BIT UPSET AND TO SELECT
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THAT
ASSUMPTION THAT THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO SORT OF RULE BY FIAT
AND HAVE IT ONLY EXPRESS ONE
VIEWPOINT BUT BE SOMETHING THAT
SIX MILLION SCHOOL CHILDREN CAN
SEE THEMSELVES IN. AFTER ONE OF.
STERN I THINK CAN DIRECTLY JOB
OF BRING THAT BRING SOME
CLARITY TO THAT OF THE
COMPLEXITY AROUND ETHNIC
STUDIES IN MY MIND IS IT A
REFLECTION OF THE QUALITY OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE OF THE
POSITION IN THE VISOR COMMITTEE
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A- REFLECTION OF
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE ISSUE.
BECAUSE WE'RE SUCH A DIVERSE
STATE WHEN YOU TRY TO TAKE A
LEGISLATION THAT LEADS TO LAWS
THAT LEADS TO FRAMEWORKS THAT
LEADS TO MODEL CURRICULUM AND
YOU HAVE TO ATTEND TO STATUTES
AND GUIDELINES AND YOU'RE
TRYING TO CAPTURE THE BREADTH
OF WHAT THE STATE REPRESENTS
AND BRING IT INTO A CONCERTED
DIFFICULT. I THINK THAT- GOING
FORWARD THERE'S BEEN A VESTED
INTEREST AND PARTNERSHIP OR
THAT DIFFERENT THAN THE
ORIGINAL KIM AND I WERE NOT
PART OF THE REGION. STAY AND
RISK. GOING FOR THIS ONE CAN AS
MENTIONED ALREADY VETTING- THE
PARTICIPANTS OF THAT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE SO THAT. NUMBER ONE
THEY THEY CAN WORK WITH OTHERS
HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS AND
NUMBER TWO THEIR OPINIONS
AREN'T THE OPINION OF THAT
REPRESENTS THE- QUALITY OF THE
STATE THE DIVERSITY THE STATE-
TO- WORKING HANDS THAT THE
VISOR COMMITTEE IS CLEAR. ABOUT
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR OR ASKING
THEM TO DO- AND THE LIMITATIONS
THEY HAVE BETTER WITHIN STATUTE.
AND THEN THREE. MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE SOMEBODY ON THIS-
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT IS
CLEARLY THE LEAD THAT CAN GUIDE
THIS WORK AND HELP MAKE
DECISIONS FOR THE ADVISORY
GROUP- THAT ARE IN ALIGNMENT
WITH WHAT HE HE U. S. SENATORS
ENVISIONED WHEN WE EMBARKED ON
THIS IDEA. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
LEARNING FROM OTHER DISTRICTS
WHO HAVE ALREADY DONE THIS WORK
SO- GOING FORWARD I CLEARLY SEE
GREATER STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT-
GREATER FEEDBACK FROM PARENTS
AND STUDENTS ABOUT WHAT THE
VALUE AND WHAT THEY NEED TO
HAVE OR WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AND
THEN ALSO LEARN FROM THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN HONEST. QUITE LONGER
THAN HALF HEARTEDLY DESIGN
ETHNIC STUDIES TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS OUT OF
THE- HIGHER THEY MAKE IT WORK
WITH A THREE JEEZ. I BELIEVE
GOING FOR THE CLEAR- CLEAR
DIRECTION THAT WILL MAKE SURE
WE GET. EARLY IN SHALL
EDUCATION FOR SURE I THINK THE
KEY IS THE KEY IS GIVING ACCESS.
OPTIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
KIDS IS WHY I CAME WHY WANT TO
VOLUNTEER HERE. AND THAT'S THE
ROLE OF THE STATE- POLITICS
CAN'T LEAD THE WAY. OUR OUR
GOAL AS A STATUS TO CREATE
OPTIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OUR STUDENTS WHETHER THAT'S
THROUGH A CHARTER SCHOOL OR
THROUGH PUBLIC SCHOOL. IN EARLY
EARLY AND- THAT'S THE MISSING
INGREDIENT. EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS- EARLY EDUCATION
AND THE OPPORTUNITY GAP GETS
BIGGER OF REALLY QUICK KIM WHAT
I WOULD CONSIDER THE EXPERT
THERE. AND AS A SUPERINTENDENT
ONE I CAN OFFER IS THAT OUR OUR
GOAL WITH OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM NOT
ONLY GIVE THEM. IT WOULD BE TO
CREATE OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS AND
KLAY EDUCATION. GIVEN THE
RESOURCES TO DO IT. AND SIR ONE
OF THE STUDIES THAT CAME OUT
THAT I FOUND JUST VERY
STARTLING LAST YEAR. ALSO WAS
FROM THE LEARNING POLICY
INSTITUTE AND IT WAS. LOOKING
AT- CALIFORNIA'S SUPPOSED TO-
OTHER STATES AROUND THE NATION
IN TERMS OF STANDARDIZED TESTS-
AND WHAT IT CONCLUDED WAS THAT
ON A YEAR TO YEAR BASIS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CHILDREN ARE
ACTUALLY. DOING PRETTY WELL
THIRTY YEAR- THAT ARE AN ANNUAL
PROGRESS AND RATES OF CHANGE
THE DELTA ESSENTIALLY- IS
PRETTY GOOD AND IN FACT IS EVEN
OUTPACING SOME OTHER- SIMILARLY
SITUATED LARGE STATES. WHERE WE
FALL DOWN IS THAT AN VERY FOR
SURE OF STANDARDIZED TESTING IN
THIRD GRADE OUR KIDS ARE COMING
IN FROM BEHIND- AND
PARTICULARLY OUR- OUR TARGET
POPULATIONS UNDER L. CFF- LOW
INCOME CHILDREN- FOSTER KIDS.
AND ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
NOT ONLY START FROM BEHIND BUT
ALSO SEE THAT GAP WIDENED YEAR
AFTER YEAR- AND SO THERE'S A
GAME OF CATCH UP THAT WE ARE
ASKING. OCEAN TO LAY OUT. THE
DATA IS TELLING US CONSISTENTLY
THAT WE ARE NOT SET UP TO BE-
THE BESTER MEDIATORS IN IN THE
COUNTRY WE ARE SET UP TO
ACTUALLY HELP CHILDREN. I HAVE
AND DO SO FROM THE BEGINNING.
AT EVER. FOURTEEN IS ACCESS.
BODY THERE SOME JOG WERE FOUR
YEAR OLDS THREE YEAR OLD TO
YOUR AND HOW ACCESS TO REALLY
LEARN AND SORT OF APPROACH TO
LEARNING THAT SAID SOME UP TO
SUCCEED IN K. TO TWELVE AND
SOME DO NOT- SO IN IN LINE WITH
FLASHERS BUDGET THAT WAS- AND
ACTED THERE IS A- UP FOR
COMING. MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY
LEARNING THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
ANNOUNCED THAT WILL BE MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN IS
MODELED AFTER THE MASTER PLAN
FOR HIGHER ED- I DON'T THINK
THE GOAL BE FOR- THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO DELIVER ALL
PROGRAMS WERE MIXED DELIVERY
STATE IN TERMS OF EARLY
LEARNING AND I THINK THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE SOMETHING THAT
HONORS HOW PARENTS CHOOSE FOR
THEIR FRIEND TO BE TICKETED AND
SOME HOME BASE SETTINGS SOME.
CARE SOME CENTER REYES SUMS TO.
BUT THE NUMBERS ARE THE ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA EDUCATE AS MANY
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS AS
THERE ARE ELEVENTH GRADERS- AND
YET THEY ARE THEY ARE LARGELY
AN AFTERTHOUGHT IN TERMS OF
SCHOOL AND ELLIE A LEVEL
PLANNING- AND SO IF WE CAN
BRING THOSE SYSTEMS TOGETHER IF
WE CAN THINK ABOUT HOW TO MAKE
THEM A PART OF OUR STRATEGIC
PLANNING EFFORTS HERE AT THE
STATE BOARD- AND ALSO PROVOKE A
CONVERSATION- MORE BROADLY.
ABOUT HOW THEY ARE INTEGRATED
AND HOW THOSE TRANSITIONS WORK
I THINK WE COULD- MAKE SIZEABLE
ON ADVANCES IN THIRD GRADE
READING MATH- AND THEN HAVE
THAT CARRY OUT THROUGHOUT THE
REMAINDER OF THEIR- K. TWELVE
CAREER. WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND AGAIN- THANK CALIFORNIA'S
FORTUNATE TO HAVE YOU BOTH
WILLING TO. IN ESSENCE
VOLUNTEER YOUR EXT PIECE TO
HELP. I THE LEADERSHIP ON THE
PART EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOU MADAM CHAIR. WITH A YOU
VERY MUCH I AM GONNA GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND ASK
IF THERE ARE PEOPLE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF. EITHER NOMINEE OR
BOTH- IF YOU'LL COME UP TO THE
MIKE- GIVE ME YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION AND BRIEF COMMENTS.
WELCOME THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON- MADAM PRO TEM AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS FOR THESE ALLEN JOB
WITH THEM WITH THE BEST PROJECT
CALIFORNIA PROUD TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF MISS BUT TELL OF
BROWN'S AND CONFIRMATION
HEARING FOR THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. SHE HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION FOR EQUITY FOR EARLY
KERN EDUCATION AND FOR K<c.cyan> TO</c>
TWELVE EDUCATION. AND SHE HAS
BEEN A CHAMPION FOR THE SYSTEMS
TO WORK TOGETHER FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF. A BETTER MAN AND
SUCCESS OFCHILDREN WERE BEING
SERVED IN THE SYSTEMS- I'VE
KNOWN WITH TO ABOUT CENTS FOR
TWELVE YEARS NOW HIS BRILLIANT
IN HER THINKING. TWO THIRTY
TAKEN HER APPROACH TO POLICY
DEVELOPMENT SHE HAS BEEN HE HAS
THE ABILITY TO CONVENE THOSE
WHO HAVE DIVERGENT POINT USE
AND BUILD CONSENSUS. I THINK
THAT IS OF GREAT VALUE WHEN IT
COMES TO POLICY MAKING.
PATELLAR BROWNSON HAS A TRACK
RECORD OF CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR KIDS OF
COLOR- SHE HAD A TRACK RECORD
OF DEVELOP POLICIES IN THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL GAP. THE
ARE MOST ONE ABOUT FOR. YOU
BRING THE PERSPECTIVE. KICKING
WORST PART IS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CALL MARKET
REP THE CHARTERS ASSIST HERE TO
SUPPORT THE COMP OF BOTH MISS
KNOB AND MISS PATEL OF BROWN'S
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE STATE
BOARD HAS A FINE TO HELP THAT
K. TWELVE POLICY FOR ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND ALSO- THE
AN ENVIABLE TASK OF OVERSEEING
AN APPEAL PROCESS FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT ARE TONIGHT AT.
ELEVEN AND FOR ALL OF US I
THINK WE CANNOT BE THAT. THE
OTHER YOU KNOW OF AT STATE
BOARD OF FAR TOO OFTEN AND SO-
THESE FOLKS ARE INCREDIBLY FAIR
MINDED- AND WE THINK THAT THEY
WILL SERVE- THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH EXCELLENCE- AND WE
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE. WITH BOTH
MEMBERS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF AB YOU KNOW FIVE A MAJOR
OVERHAUL OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACT THAT WOULD HELP NEGOTIATE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA. TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION LAST- THAT TIMIDLY
DICTATE. IMPART HOW THE APPEALS
PROCESS AT THE STATE BOARD- IS
CHANGED OVER TIME. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH BOTH-
I'M MEMBERS AS WELL ON AT AS A
ROBUST SECOND LOOK. THAT'S THAT
WILL ACCOUNT. BEAU ACT GROWTH
AND SECONDARY OUTCOME WINTER
SCHOOLS ARE COMING BEFORE THEIR
REVIEW SO CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THAT WAS HELPFUL
WELCOME. MARTHA'S HEARING THOSE
IDEAS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND WE
SUPPORT BOTH- MR MAT NOVEL AND
MISS KIM PATILLO BRONSON. AND
SECURE YES VOTE ON THEIR
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. THEY BRING
WITH THEM BROAD- EXPERIENCE
EXPERTISE MISTER NOT ALL IN THE
AREA OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
HIS WORK EXPERIENCES FOR
INTENDED OF A DISK SCHOOL
DISTRICT. IN A RURAL AREA SO
BRINGS WITH HIM A- CRISP. THAT
NOT NECESSARILY BEEN IGNORED
PURPOSEFULLY BUT WE NEED CARE
MORE ABOUT THE- FACED BY SCHOOL
IT'S TO THAT ARE IN ROLE IN.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT HE WILL
BRING THAT EXPERTISE AND THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND HOW TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES AT THE STATE
BOARD. MISS K<c.cyan> MISS CAMP</c>
TILL ONSEN BRINGS WITH HER HER
EXPERTISE AND WORK EXPERIENCE
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS OF SYSTEMS
DEVELOPMENT EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. AND IT'S NOT A QUICK.
LEE THE BOAT OR WORK EXPERIENCE
AND THEIR EXPERTISE WELL-
PROVIDE STE THEY WILL BE STRONG
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION WHEN DEVELOPING AN
IMPORTANT AREAS SUCH AS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. OF OUR-
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. WELL WE
KNOW THAT THEY WILL- PROVIDE
INPUT IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
WELL INFORMED EDUCATION POLICY
THAT WILL RESULT IN BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR ALL CHILDREN
INCLUDING THOSE WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS NG AND ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND- OUR DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS
AND- EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
GRAMS THAT WITH BOTH MR NOT AND
KIM PORTAIL ONCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FOR WITH THIS VALLEY
EDGE CALL WE- A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT- LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES SERVING MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
THE COUNTIES OF FRESNO KING
MADERA AND MARIPOSA WERE SAID
TO LARRY- WE APPRECIATE IN
SUPPORT THE APPOINTMENT OF
MISTER NAVAJO. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT HIS LOCAL- EXPERIENCE IN
THE DISTRICT HAS STATE
EXPERIENCE AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND HIS OF- WORK. TO EDUCATION
WILL BE A GREAT ASSET TO MEN
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
LOOK TO WORK COMING TO PASS
THANK. COULD I. MADAM BUT TEN
MEMBERS AT THAT'S WHAT FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL IT PRE
**** INTO OF BOTH NOMINEES
FIRST WITH TO BROWN TO WE WORK
WITH HER IN ITS ORGANIZATION
PROBLEM TIME MINUTES YOU HEARD
AND NOT JUST HER INTELLECT SHE
BRINGS TO THIS CAPACITY BUT I
THINK YOU FOR THE HARD PRESSED
TO FIND A BIGGER CHAMPION
YOUNGEST STUDENT STATE IS THAT
WAS EVIDENT BUT NOT ONLY SO
MUCH OF THE RIGHT NOW IT IT ON
THE- BACK. THAT EVERY ISSUE.
LOOKS NOW THE MOST. IN THE
STATE SO. ON THE BOARD IN THE
WORK HAS ALREADY BEEN FELT INTO
MISTER NOVEL AS THE
ADMINISTRATOR AS OF. WE'RE VERY
SENSITIVE TO HAVING THE
PERSPECTIVE A EDUCATOR THERE IN
THIS POLICY MAKING BODY-
HAPPENS IN THIS BUILDING HERE
IN THE STATE BOARD OF ED AND I
ARE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND MORE OFTEN NOT
ARE FOR ONE IN THAT SOMEBODY
WHO'S SITTING IN THAT SEAT.
WHAT IT IS TO IMPLEMENT VARIOUS
AGAIN AS YOU MISTER BIBLE
EXPLAIN HIS EXPERTISE AND HIM
BEING VERY DEEP IN THIS ALREADY
IN OUR SYSTEM OF SUPPORT AND
THE. NEWS THEM ACCOUNTABILITY
IS HUGE RESOURCE TO ALL OF US
IN THE FIELD WHO WE ARE SUPPORT
BOTH NOMINEES THINK. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SMITH A TREND
WITH CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT OF
BOTH NOMINEES AS WELL- WE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
BOTH MET MS PATIL BRONSON AND
MISTER JOB THOUGH AND I THINK
IT'S OTHER SPOKE THE SPEAKERS
OF COMMENTED- A MS PATIL SO
THIS AWFUL AND DELIBERATIVE AND
A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR BOTH KIDS
AND HIS DEMENS. BOTH OF THE
LOCAL ON THE STATE LEVEL A REAL
FOCUS ON MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING RIGHT BY BY THE KIDS
THAT. ARE MOST IN MOST NEED OUR
SUPPORT IN ADDITION A MISTER
NAVAJO HIS WORK IN SAYING
HERE'S SOMETHING TO LOOK TO AND
SEE THE- THE ABILITY TO BRING
EDUCATORS AND COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER TO REALLY THINK ABOUT.
CHANGE IMPACTING OUR TEACHING
IN AND FUNDAMENTAL WAYS WE'VE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE ROLE ON. IT
LEVEL AT CAL PRETTY PACKED.
BUYS REGROUP THAT THE BOARD- A
POINTS AS WELL AS- THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE SO HE
HAS THAT STATE LOCAL EXPERIENCE
AND- TRANSIT BUS AS WE'VE BEEN
IMPROVING SOME. VISION THANKS.
TO THE SO. LOOKING FOR WORK
WITH BOTH COMPANIES IN THE
YEARS AHEAD THANK YOU. THANK.
AFTERNOON I'M YES IN GRAY WALL
CO YOUR PA PIANO. AT CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS STATE WHY EARLY SHOW
TO PAUL NOT TO THE ORGAN. ON
BEHALF OF EARLY EDGE I'M
PLEASED TO RECOMMEND MISS KIM
PATELLA BROWNSON IS A HIGHLY
QUALIFIED APPOINTMENT TO THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION. WE
EARLY AGE OF IT PLEASE LOOK.
CLOSE IN COLLABORATIVELY WITH
MS PADILLA BROWNSON OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS SHE JOINED OUR
EAST COAST EARLY LEARNING TOUR
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AND
ARE TOWARD TO CHICAGO IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO LEARN HOW
OTHER STATES AND LOCALITIES ARE
BUILDING HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING SYSTEMS AND IMPROVING
ONLINE BETWEEN EARLY LEARNING
AND K. THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEMS.
ACROSS ALL OF OUR EXPERIENCES
TOGETHER. MS PADILLA BROWN AND
HAS IMPRESSED ME WITH HER
PASSION. COLLEGE IN DEEP
BANDING OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
EARLY LEARNING FOR THE CONTINUE
ONE. OF CHILD'S EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE OUR DEDICATION TO
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY AND TO
LIFTING UP BLOWING I'M STUDENTS
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR. OKAY
OPEN AN EDUCATION CALIFORNIA
IMPROVE OPPORTUNE AND OUT FOR
ALL CHILDREN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MONEY
CRIMINALS ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE LA HERE IN SUPPORT OF
MISTY OF BRONSON'S APPOINTMENT
WE BELIEVE THAT HER CAREER
COMMITMENT TO EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY AS WELL AS EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS IMPAIRED
THE STATE BOARD IN ORDER TO
BETTER BLEND IN BRIGHT OUR
SYSTEMS AND ENSURE THAT OUR
EARLIER MINOR START. PLAYING
FIELD THANK THANK YOU. PETER
BERG'S ALL OF CASH ATTEND SO
SHE XIN WE BOTH NOMINEES WE
WORK WITH BOTH INDIVIDUALS
BEFORE THEY JOINED THE BOARD
WE'VE WORKED WITH THEM NOW
THEY'VE BEEN ON THE BOARD-
THEIR FARM THEY BRING HIM. IN
VERSE TO PURSUE THE FED
EXPERIENCE TO THE BOARD AND
THEY'RE VERY COLLABORATIVE SO
WE RECOMMEND APPROVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MANNA PRO TEM
AND MEMBERS I'M BRIAN RIVAS
REPRESENTING THE EDUCATION
TRUST WEST AND HERE TO ASK TO
SUPPORT MS. PATIL BROWNSON ASK
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF HER
CONFIRMATION- WEREN'T EQUITY
ORGANIZATION THAT THIS FOCUSED
ON CLOSING OPPORTUNITY AN
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND MS PATIL BROWN'S AND ONE OF
OUR AFFECTED PARTNERS. AN
EXPERT IN CHILD CARE AND EARLY
LEARNING. HER APPROACH TO THE
WORK. IS EXCEPTIONAL SHE'S
GUIDED BY RESEARCHING DATA
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT
TO SEE BUT ALSO. A PASSION FOR
LISTENING TO ME AND IT IS AN
INSURANCE. WAS WITH LEAST DOES
GET WHAT THEY NEED. IS CONFIRM
HER THANK. YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MARTHA ALBERTSON HAVE THE LOS
ANGELES IF I SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IN SUPPORT OF BOTH AND ON HOW
MANY. AFTER SOME MENTION
MYSTERY NOVEL AND THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S REALLY FOCUSING ON
SPECIAL OCCASION RIGHT HOW DO
WE- KEEP. TABS MISTER PROBABLY.
MS PATIL BROWN SAID- WE HAVE
HAD EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH HER I'M WITH THE
LA UNIFIED IN AN EFFORT TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR OUR
STUDENTS- EARLY EDUCATION WE
UNDERSTAND IS A PRIORITY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AB
AND ALL OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THAT WE CALL BUT-
I'M- ANOTHER COMMENTS WE REALLY
IS THAT TO OUR NOMINEES AREN'T
IMPORTANT VOICES FOR ELECTED OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I SEE NO FURTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I AM AND WE WILL
TAKE BOTH A AND B. TOGETHER
THAT IS THE MOTION MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES FACE AYE MONNING
MONNING HI ROSS ROSS I WILL
WILK AYE ATKINS KEN SORRY.
GRADUATIONS UNANIMOUS. YEAH.
WELL THANK YOU ALL AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS I WILL GO AHEAD
AND INVITE UP THE HONORABLE
SUSAN MONIA. AND AS SHE COMES
UP MEMBER OF THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL APPEALS BOARD.
I WE'LL LET PEOPLE EXIT BEFORE
WE ASK YOU TO START. I NOTICED
YOU WERE DEEPLY ENGAGED IN THAT
CONVERSATION AND NODDING YOUR
HEAD IT WAS. IT'S WELCOME
REFLEX REACTION. A WELL I KNOW
YOUR EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND ARE
YOUR WORK BACKGROUND AS WELL SO
LET ME WELCOME YOU AND I ASK IF
YOU WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE
AND YOUR COMMENTS AND THEN YOU
KNOW WE'LL GO RIGHT TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS WELL
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY- I WOULD
HAVE MY FAMILY IS NOT HERE BUT
I'D ALWAYS DO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM
THIS IS WE ON HER CASE SUPPORT
US IN. ALL OUR VENTURES PROJECT
PUBLIC SERVICE FAMILY IS ALWAYS
BE INVOLVED AND SO I'M GRATEFUL
TO THEM- IT'S REALLY AN HONOR
TO BE APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR
KNEW SOME TO THIS POSITION AND
THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
OF THE BOARD- AND I'M ALSO VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME HERE AND MEET WITH YOU AND
SINCE. I'VE BEEN ON THE SINCE
LAST EIGHT LEARNING A LOT AND
TO REALLY HAVE FOUND THAT- THE
WHAT I HAVE BEEN COMMITTED TO
IN MY YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE
WHICH IS- DUE PROCESS GOOD
GOVERNANCE- THAT THIS ROLE
REALLY AFFORDS ME THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE IN THAT
COMPLETELY SEPARATELY- FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE PROVIDE THAT
VERY IMPORTANT CHECK AND
BALANCE FUNCTION- FOR THE
PUBLIC AND FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHERE THE APPEAL
CAN BE MADE OUT TO US AS A
SEPARATE ENTITY. FROM THE IN
ITSELF AND SO I THINK OUR
PURSUIT- AND ONE OF THE THINGS
I'VE LEARNED AND CONTINUE TO
LEARN AND I'M ENJOYING AND- IN
THIS ROLE IS THE- ABILITY AND
THE UNDERSTANDING OF HOW WE
WANT TO WORK TOWARDS GREATER
COMPLIANCE FOR BETTER BUSINESS
FIRE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHEN. VIOLATING THEIR LIE THAT
IS WHEN WE TEND TO SEE THEM
BECAUSE THEY THEN APPEAL. A
RULING FROM THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE-
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY NOT ONLY TO BE- A
CHECK AND BALANCE UPON THE
DEPARTMENT ITSELF- AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE- LICENSEE
TO FEEL THAT THEY ARE GETTING
THEIR DUE PROCESS- AND THAT
THEY WILL BE HEARD IT BEFORE US
BUT- ALSO- REALLY. MOVING
TOWARDS A CULTURE WHERE
COMPLIANCE IS OUR GOAL-
ENFORCEMENT IS PART OF
COMPLIANCE BUT WE REALLY DO
WANT TO SEE OUR BUSINESSES-
FUNCTIONING WITHIN THE
PARAMETERS OF THEIR LICENSE-
FOR THE BENEFIT OF BUSINESS FOR
THE PUBLIC AND FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES AS WELL SO IT'S BEEN
VERY FASCINATING I'VE FOUND IT-
INTERESTING AND- A REALLY
WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS AND
WE'LL TRY TO ANSWER THEM TO THE
BEST OF. MY ABILITY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH LET ME START WITH YOU
SENATOR MONNING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- MS MONEY- WELCOME
HOME. HE AND I ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY AND I
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
TODAY I DO THINK- IT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL FOR MY COLLEAGUES WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT I KNOW THAT
YOU MADE THE DISTINCTION THE
DEPARTMENT VERSUS THE APPEALS
BOARD BUT IN TERMS OF
FACILITATING ENGAGEMENT YOU
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT- THE
GOAL OF ELECTRONIC FILING
POTENTIAL OR PARTICIPATION
ELECTRONICALLY HE COULD JUST
SHARE A LITTLE BIT THE STATUS
OF THAT IN WHAT THE HOPE IS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION- YES I REALLY
FEEL- OPTIMISTIC AND POSITIVE
ABOUT SOME OF THE- CHANGES THAT
WE'RE IN ACTING CURRENTLY- AT
THE APPEALS BOARD- E. FILING
ITS WERE GETTING INTO WHATEVER
CENTURY WERE IN NOW YOU KNOW
AND- AND NOT EXPECTING EVERYONE
HOPEFULLY. FIND STAMP AND MAIL
ALL OF THEIR PAPERWORK TO US-
WHICH IS THE CURRENT STATE AND
SO- WE ARE HOPING TO HAVE THAT
PLEASE BY THE WE- CONFERENCE
CALLING. AND THIS IS IMPORTANT
YOU KNOW USUALLY ON OUR MEETING
IT'S M<c.cyan> OFTEN THE INTER.</c>
THAT ARE THERE- SOME OF THEIR
CLIENTS ACTUALLY COME THE
ACTUAL LICENSEES SOME PEOPLE
DO. REPRESENT THEMSELVES- AS
WELL BUT WHEN YOU HAD ATTORNEY
COMING- TO REPRESENT A CLIENT
WE NOW WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
FOR THE ACTUAL LICENSEE IF THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO APPEAR OR TRAVEL
TO THE HEARING COULD LISTEN IN-
TO THE HEARING ITSELF. AND SO I
FEEL THAT WE'RE MAKING SOME
IMPORTANT STEPS BIRDS INCREASED
ACCESSIBILITY FOR THE PUBLIC
AND INCREASED TRANSPARENCY
BECAUSE NOW- MORE PEOPLE WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
HEAR WHAT WE'RE DOING. IN OUR
APPEALS HEARINGS THREE WILL YOU
SO MUCH AND I HAVE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS TIME AND AGAIN.
BEFORE I THINK FOR YOUR
CONTINUED. TO SERVER. EIGHT I
THANK YOU AND LET ME ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE COMMON SO THANK YOU
FOR STEPPING UP ABOUT SEASON WE
HAD A GREAT TIME A CONVERSATION
IN MY OFFICE SO I DON'T HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BUT
CERTAINLY ANOTHER HIGH FIVING
CONGRATULATIONS AND NOT HAS YOU
COVERED- THE ROLE THAT YOU PLAY
ON APPEALS VERSUS THE OUR
AGENCY ITSELF AND SOME OF THE
ISSUES ADAM STREET. WITHOUT I
THINK KIND OF A BUMPY PEELS
PROCESS FOR ONE RESTAURANT WE
FEEL THAT YOU ARE VERY OPEN- TO
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS WHOLE
SELF AND ASK. SO
CONGRATULATIONS OF FOR YOUR
NOMINATION YOUR APPOINTMENT AND
YOU WILL HAVE MY- A HUGE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. MY THE
MAYES MESS WITH ME AND I DON'T
LIKE. HAPPEN EVERY TIME TODAY
CONGRATULATIONS I DID ASK FOR
MEETING HAD THE HONOR AND
PLEASURE OF SERVING WITH YOU IN
YOUR PERCENT INTEGRITY AND YOU
HAVE A PASSION FOR GOOD
GOVERNMENT I KNOW YOU CAN DO A
GREAT JOB SO IT'S APPROPRIATE
TIME AND PUT WOULD LIKE TO MOVE.
THIS BUT THIS I JUST SOMETHING
AND I KNOW YOU'RE THE FOUR
TIMES THROW SOME OUT AND THEN
BECAUSE I'M WORKING IT
ADMINISTRATIVE BUT A FEW YEARS
AGO PLAYING MOST IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WAS KERRY
BY MYSELF AND TOM DALY AND A
LOUD NAIL SALONS AND- SHOPS IN
IN HAIRDRESSING SALONS TO SERVE
ONE MOMENT YOUR GLASS OF BEER
OR WINE. AND THE BOARD SO AT
THE AGENCIES ALLOWING IT FOR
BARBER SHOPS AND HAIRS SALON
AND HERE'S OUR SONGS BUT OFFER
NAIL SALONS AND SO IS CRAZY I'M
WORKING AND I DON'T WANT TO DO
ANOTHER PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND I WANTED TO
ADMINISTRATIVELY BUT I JUST
WANT TO BE AWARE THAT IF
THERE'S ANYTHING YOU CAN DO TO
HELP NINE YEAR AND BECAUSE ITS-
OWN IT'S THE LAW NATION IN
THERE NOT IT THEY'RE NOT
ENFORCING IT. OUR HI DOGMEAT I
USED TO GO TO A NICE PLACE TO
GO TO NOW SINCE I GOT THE
SENATE I MIGHT MY LIFESTYLES
WAY LESS THAN WHAT IT USED TO
BE BY IT'S SOMETHING HE IS
RIGHT RIGHT FABRICLAND FALL
AROUND. OVER YOU ANYWAY. SO BUT
NOW. OR NOT ALLOWING US LOANS
AND EVEN THOUGH WAS IN THE BILL
SO. WHERE. MOVING ON TO SENATOR
ROTH WHO OBVIOUSLY WILL NOT BE
MAKING THE MOTION THAT MATTERED
PRO TO. GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS FOR CONTINUING
TO STEP UP TO THE PLATE AND
I'LL BE VOTING TO SUPPORT YOUR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM THANK YOU- I WOULD JUST
SAY I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
BALANCE APPROACH IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS BECAUSE THESE
ARE. VERY DIFFICULT SITUATIONS
WHEN THEY RISE TO THIS LEVEL
AND THEY HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
IMPACT ON THE BUSINESS ON THE
COMMUNITY YOU MAY EAT. ALONG
BOTH SIDES OF WHAT SHOULD
HAPPEN TO IT TWO KILLER
LICENSEE SO AN OBJECTIVE. OUR
APPROACH TO RESOLVING THESE
ISSUES IS GREATLY APPRECIATED-
I DON'T HAVE A QUESTIONS- I
WILL GO TO THE PUBLIC SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION. MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN YOUR MOTION IS IN
ORDER. SENATORS BATES HI BATES
I MONNING MINING HI ROSS ROSS I
WILL WILK AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS
AYE CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU
AND- WE WILL MOVE TO EXECUTIVE
SESSION. IN JUST A MOMENT.